انتقال سلمي للسلطة هذا ما
رأيناه دائمًا
أليكس ماركوارت ما يحدث حيث
تكون أليكس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
حسنًا ، لقد عدنا إلى الجانب الغربي
من العاصمة ، ما يمكنك سماعه
هناك وميض أه من المفترض
قوة الشرطة هذه التي تحركت لتوها في
الذئب ما تنظر إليه الآن هو ما تراه الآن
شرطة العاصمة من واشنطن العاصمة التي انتقلت
قبل حظر التجول الساعة 6 مساءً
إلى هنا لطرد
الدراجين الذين كانوا يصرخون
بالعودة إلى هذا الحشد من  المئات
إن لم يكن أكثر من مؤيدي ترامب على
الجانب الغربي
من مبنى الكابيتول ، هذا الذئب هو
المكان الذي
سيتم فيه افتتاح الرئيس المنتخب بايدن
في الخلفية في غضون 14 يومًا بالضبط ، يمكنك
رؤية نصب واشنطن التذكاري
الذي قررت الشرطة الآن بعد
عدة ساعات
من ذلك.  تجمع حاشد ضخم على
الجانب الغربي من مبنى الكابيتول
لطردهم ، لقد سمعنا تقارير
عن الغاز المسيل
للدموع لم أر ذلك في اللحظات القليلة الماضية
ولكن ليس هناك شك في
أن العاصمة  لن يتردد قسم شرطة أوليتان
وكذلك وكالات إنفاذ القانون الأخرى
هنا ، حيث طُلب منا العودة إلى الوراء ، نعم
ضابط ،
سنرى هذا الضابط على سبيل المثال
مجهزًا بالكامل
بمعدات مكافحة الشغب وكما كنت
أقول الذئب
لم نحصل عليه  الانطباع بأنهم
سيترددون في استخدام إجراءات مكافحة الشغب
هذه لإبعاد هذه الجماهير من المشاغبين
عن العاصمة
التي هاجموها وكانوا أه
الذي دخلوا فيه
أه على مدار فترة الذئب بعد الظهر ،
نعم يجب عليهم استخدام
كل الكائنات أه ضروري ل  احصل على هذا
تحت السيطرة ، هذا وصمة عار
ما يحدث على تلة الكابيتول
الآن آه
فقط كن حذرًا هناك ، تعلم
أننا سنبقى على مقربة
منك
للتواصل معك أليكس